Khloe Kardashian's baby bump makes its
debut plus more on Disney Channel's
first gay character hi friends this is
the daily denne and stop the presses
because we finally have our first look
at Khloe Kardashian's growing baby bump
and we know the sex of the baby et has
learned that Khloe and Cleveland
Cavaliers star Tristan Thompson are
having a boy today khlo was snapped in
New York City filming Keeping Up with
the Kardashians where we got a peek of
the belly now if there's one thing this
photo proves it's that we are in for
some legit pregnancy fashion from
khlomoney
probably because she has lots of it you
feel me Chloe and Tristan are expecting
their first child and not only have they
been relatively quiet about it on social
media
neither have outright confirmed the news
rest of the family has been tight-lipped
as well though momager Kris Jenner told
us just this week how happy she is for
where Khloe is in her life right now you
guys know Joyce over the moon yeah I am
so over-the-moon we love Tristan so much
and she's so happy and she's been
through so much and I think that just
seeing her be able to do something so
creative with good American on top of it
to have and be in such a great place in
her personal life is amazing yeah she's
she's really happy she's really happy
but I'm I think it's still very weird to
me that the kardashian-jenner has have
not been more vocal about Chloe or
Kylie's pregnancy like we don't have
time to wait until the season finale of
your show you guys let's talk about it
meanwhile Disney Channel is going where
the network has never gone before a key
character in one of the shows on the
mouse house will come out as gay that's
right in and Emax season 2 premiere
Cyrus played by Joshua Rush will realize
he has feelings for a male classmate the
episode airs tomorrow and will show
Cyrus opening up to his and Andy's best
friend Buffy about his feelings Buffy's
reaction is intended to serve as a
positive example for both children and
adults in a statement to Deadline a
Disney Channel spokesperson said quote
Andy Mack is a story about tweens
figuring out who they are
creator Terri Minsky the cast and
everyone involved in the show takes
great care
and ensuring that it's appropriate for
all audiences and sends a powerful
message about inclusion and respect for
humanity gay characters have appeared in
other Disney Channel shows but this is
the first time a young character has
realized that he or she is gay on the
network and you guys will remember we
just had Luna blaze from
fresh-off-the-boat on our show and her
15 year old character on the ABC series
just came out as lesbian rare to see
these kind of storylines on network TV
let alone on the Disney Channel although
I've always had my questions about Gordo
what do you guys think any other shows
need a gay character or another good
coming-out story let us know in the
comments section below but moving on to
night 2 of the World Series Dodgers
versus the Astros among the stars
cheering on the boys in blue Justin
Timberlake who is like the rest of this
town emotional wrecks it was the place
to be even though it was a rough night
for the Dodger fans
I still haven't scored a ticket but ash
crossing was there with none other than
country superstar Brad Paisley just
before he sang the national anthem Danny
it's true I am once again and not
wearing a headset but for some reason
they did let me back on the field at the
2017 World Series we've got game two
coming up in just a couple of hours I
just talked to Brad Paisley backstage
who was singing the national anthem and
yeah he's pickin size I don't think I
need to ask you who you're rooting for
because look I wish no ill will towards
the Astros but it's really I mean I've
been a Dodger fan for awhile and it's
really gonna be fun to see what happens
I think I saw you mix it up with the
players watching batting practice I mean
what kind of conversations do you guys
have tonight I don't what to do they
asked me if I had any ideas I told of
course I'm like who's pep-talking who
out it would be interesting to see if
they listen to now does Brad Paisley get
nervous I mean the national anthem I'm I
mean you can correct me if I'm wrong but
I feel like that is like one of the most
difficult songs to perform it can be I
mean one of the things that is difficult
about it is every
he knows it they know what it ought to
be how taught us sound they all have
their image in their mind and so you're
up there delivering something that they
think they know what it ought to be as
opposed to something new or something
that I sing already for me this is this
is America's pastime and the chance to
get up in this venue where I've had
incredible memories already I brought my
kids to the first major league baseball
game here and become friends with some
of these players it's an amazing
experience to be able to go up there and
save these guys
[Music]
Game three in Houston is tomorrow and
speaking of tomorrow we have Jennifer
McAllister a k-8 Gen X pen in the house
she's stopping by to talk season three
of her YouTube read series for some so
be sure to subscribe to our Channel and
check your notifications you guys so you
don't miss it
alright I'm gonna bat out of here again
[Applause]
[Music]